[Aplausos]
[Música]
y
buenas tardes gracias más el año pasado
en marzo cuando me propusieron hacer una
charla ted que desconocía cuál era cuál
era la dinámica de estas cosas y me puse
a pensar en que en que podía contar al
público
tras unos cuantos objetivos y pasar un
poco por mi vida y las experiencias de
mi vida y hablaba de mí un año después
un año y unos meses después todos
llevamos dentro una procesión que nos ha
hecho crecer que nos ha hecho vivir
dolor pero sobre todo que nos ha hecho
reflexionar hoy quiero hacer el mismo
recorrido porque yo no he cambiado
aparentemente pero tiene un sentido de
agradecimiento al otro al otro a los
demás a vosotros
a la gente que me ha hecho crecer en la
vida a la gente que me ha dado la mano y
me ha aportado
este año me han pasado otras cosas
importantes en el camino
una que acaba de suceder hoy mi hijo se
acaba de examinar del último examen de
la abao es decir dejó de ser madre de
niños de colegio 12 me he hecho
profesora titular a parte de mi carrera
como actriz a la enseño verso clásico en
la universidad cosa que me llena de
orgullo y me hace pasar el testigo a los
otros y mi reflexión durante este año ha
sido que debemos ir haciendo un cierre
de círculo cerrar el círculo es
importante y a mí no se me ocurre otra
manera de cerrar el círculo que dar las
gracias a la gente que está a mi lado y
que me ha abierto los ojos como estos
que os digo
cuando yo era pequeña quise ser actriz y
no me preguntáis por qué porque
reflexiono y todavía tengo dudas yo creo
que viene de una cosa en la que está
investigando que tampoco tengo ni idea
creo que hay una científica maravillosa
que sabe de esto yo no tengo ni idea
pero hay una teoría que se llama teoría
de cuerdas y que dice que nuestras
primeras moléculas partículas no son no
son estáticas sino que somos vibración
que somos una vibración que somos como
un lazo que vibra nuestra primera
nuestra primera y pequeña esencia debe
ser eso porque yo mis primeros recuerdos
que yo no sé si son conscientes o
inconscientes o recuerdos de lo que me
han contado siempre me ponen un ritmo me
recuerdo
en una cama de matrimonio con mi padre
sábado o domingo por la mañana y mis
hermanos
recitando poemas mi padre y nosotros
siguiéndoles con palmas con pitos con
gritos yo era un bebé porque soy la
pequeña de cuatro hermanos y empezábamos
así los sábados por la mañana no haberme
equivocado
[Música]
un poquito más despacio decíamos por la
mañana un ricachón mentecato ahorrador
empedernido por comprar jamón barato lo
compró medio podrido le produjo
indigestión y entre bote caiga le no
gasto el doble que en jamón por no
comprar jamón bueno hoy afirman que es
un loco saber economizar no es gastar
mucho ni poco sino saberlo gastar y me
pareciã niños y no saberlo gastar sino
saberlo gastar y eso esa vibración esa
repetición
ese metrónomo esa vibración son mis
primeros recuerdos de pequeña mis
primeras sensaciones
son una vibración y eso me ha acompañado
y yo creo que quise ser actriz por ser
la portadora de esas vibraciones por eso
mi dedicación al verso mi gusto por el
teatro clásico mi acercamiento a la
música a la partitura a lo sonoro
después llega mi hermana después llega
mi hermana y en la preadolescencia
me habla de un poema y me dice con este
resabio que tienen las niñas de 15 y 16
años tu has leído este poema
qué más le doy y me dice
y me habla de un poema que habla de un
hombre a su mujer un hombre que está en
la guerra y le habla de amor a su mujer
recién embarazada y le dice que está con
ella a mí me parece la sensualidad hecha
carne en la palabra me conmueve
le digo bueno no había internet como os
podéis imaginar dónde lo has buscado
dímelo dónde está alem el otra vez y
ella con ya una adolescente crecidita me
mira yo tenía 10 u 11 años y me dice ve
como te ha gustado tanto y le digo si me
ha gustado mucho
empieza supongo que con esa vibración y
con ese ritmo a sentir que el alma se me
esponja va de cosas de nuestra vida
sensuales y de un amor que se iba que
iba empezando a forjarse no también
hacia los demás y dice así
[Música]
el poblado tu vientre de amor y
sementera
[Música]
he prolongado el eco de sangre a que
respondo
y espero sobre el surco como él ha dado
espera
[Música]
he llegado hasta el fondo
morena de altas torres alta luz y altos
ojos
esposa de mi piel
gran trago de mi vida
tus pechos locos crecen hacia mí dando
saltos de sierva concebida
ya me parece que eres un cristal
delicado
tengo que temer rompas al más leve
tropiezo y a reforzar tus venas con mi
piel de soldado
fuera
como el cerezo
espejo de mi carne
sustento de mis alas
te doy vida en la muerte que me dan
y no tomo
mujer
te quiero cercado por las malas
ansiado por el plomo
y seguiría y seguiría el poema es mucho
más largo es la carta en forma de poema
le escribe miguel hernández desde
que me voy de luz vaya para ser actriz
le escribe miguel hernández desde desde
la guerra desde la trinchera a su mujer
no esas palabras me llegan al corazón y
yo empiezo a investigar me empiezan a
llevar a ir a madrid al teatro empiezo a
ver que el teatro y que hay una
profesión que existe que se dedica a eso
yo me miro al espejo y lloro y soy muy
teatrera y estas cosas y entonces se va
haciendo en mi carne un deseo una
vocación que luego afortunadamente he
podido llevar a cabo
esto mi padre luego mi hermana y luego
ya llega la mía mi adolescencia el punto
cumbre el punto culminante donde me pasa
algo que podría estar muy relacionado
con las charlas ted porque yo tuve una
visión
alguien tuvo una revela revelación en mí
en forma de maestro maestro de filosofía
del segundo debut de tercero debut un
hombre josé maría pacheco del que no
encontrado mucha información después que
que tenía la desgracia de estar medio
año en el psiquiátrico y medio año dando
clase a unos alumnos que le esperábamos
pero hoy era muy tarde era muy
desorganizado
pero era un visionario entonces yo que
ya empezaba a tener mi vena artística
escribo en la pizarra porque el maestro
no venía esta canción
dos gardenias para ti
[Música]
pongo la pizarra esta canción a mí a mis
compis algunos se juntan y la cantamos
entre todos a sin pan casi pues eso muy
muy agitados no cómo sería
si la queréis cantar conmigo qué ilusión
dos gardenias para ti con ellas quiero
decir
te quiero
te adoro yo le decía venga vamos mi vida
vida
ponles toda tu atención porque son tu
corazón el mío
los cargos
para ti que tendrán todo el calor
de un mes o de esos pesos que te di y
que jamás encontrarás en el calor de
otro querer
a tu lado vivirán
y te hablarán o cuando estás conmigo
y hasta credo
las que te dirán
te quiero y aquí lo dejo porque no me
dio tiempo pero este maestro llegó nos
sentamos todos rápido después de estar
cantando ahí como bien fuerte la canción
miro la pizarra yo digo va a
pensar va a decir quien la escrito y
empezó a subrayar los pronombres dos
gardenias para ti con ya que yo de ti te
quiero te adoro mi vida porque toda tu
atención y nos dijo que os parecen los
pronombres pronombres es vivir en el
otro estar en el otro conmigo tu yo de
mi la tradición oral tiene muchos
pronombres posesivos y nos escribió en
la pizarra entonces un poema de salinas
el poeta del amor que para mí es una
demostración del amor grande de los
profesores este año terminó de ser madre
de niños de col este año la vida me
lleva a ejercer como docente profesión
que siempre he deseado y este año me
lleva a cerrar el círculo de este año de
peregrinación a través de nuestros
deseos de nuestro dolor y saber que
necesitamos más los unos de los otros y
nos enseña este poema llenado de
pronombres de pedro salinas que dice así
[Música]
perdóname por ir así buscándote tan
torpemente dentro de ti
perdóname el dolor alguna vez
[Música]
es que quiero sacar de ti
tú mejor tú
s que no te viste y que yo veo nadador
por tu fondo preciosismo
y cogerlo y tenerlo yo en lo alto como
tiene el árbol la luz su última que le
ha encontrado al sol
[Música]
y entonces tú en su busca vendrías
a lo alto
para llegar a él su vida sobre ti como
te quiero
tocando ya tan solo a tu pasado
con las puntas rosadas de tus pies
en tensión todo el cuerpo
[Música]
ya ascendiendo de ti a ti misma
y que a mi amor entonces le contesté
la nueva criatura que tú eras
gracias profesor
gracias papá gracias hermana
gracias amigos
[Aplausos]
[Música]